en bleu à l'invino éducateur sportif
spécialiste de boxe anglaise et
française il entraîne Olivier Martinez
et nous dit Bouchez et quelques autres
en noir rush disais qui vient
d'apprendre à boxer pour les besoins
d'un tournage on le voit en ce moment
dans n'oublie pas que tu vas mourir et
en avoir ou pas porter d'un jeune
comédien quand on grandit en banlieue
qu'on appelle diplôme et qu'on est un
peu feignant comme moi il y a pas 36
solutions quoi alors en fait
je me souviens que j'ai commencé à faire
du théâtre uniquement parce que ce qui
est beaucoup de filles dans les cours de
théâtre et notamment donc il y en a une
où j'étais amoureuse et je l'ai suivi
jusqu'au cours du théâtre et en fait
pendant 6 mois je m'intéressais à elle
et puis ensuite pendant deux trois ans
je me suis intéressé au théâtre donc
c'est comme ça que c'est venu quoi
[Musique]
ça veut dire que vous ressemblez à votre
personnage dans le film de Laetitia
Masson
à cause
tu es vraiment pas le bon exemple
d'intérim avec toutes les nanas avec moi
parce qu'en fait je regrette un peu
cette époque où
c'était l'insouciance
c'est vrai que je me souciais pas du
lendemain je réfléchissais à rien et
c'était un peu ouais comme dans le
personnage de du film de Laetitia ou le
type c'était bon bah vive le moment
présent et en fait c'est une très bonne
méthode mais après avec la maturité on
la perd quoi on pense au lendemain à
l'avenir
après le film que j'ai vu au cinéma
c'était dix commandements j'ai été
vachement impressionné par l'ouverture
de la mer
et puis après je me suis ouais ensuite
après je me suis intéressé au jeu de
l'acteur parce que c'est Patrick dewer
moi qui m'a vachement marqué quand
j'étais plus jeune et donc c'est lui qui
est qui a fait que je me suis intéressé
au
jeu quoi en lui-même et non pas à
l'action pourquoi lui en particulier
qu'est-ce qu'il avait de plus qu'il
avait j'ai moins ce qu'il avait mais je
le savoir mais je sais pas pourtant
j'étais très jeune quand j'ai découvert
deux verres mais c'est pas lui je me
suis je me suis tout de suite intéressé
à la personne comment comment y jouer tu
sais on avait on a l'impression qu'il
jouait pas quoi c'est ça qui
m'impressionnait chez lui mais moi
j'aime tous les personnages qui sont qui
sont assez éloignés de moi
ou un petit peu mais j'aimerais pas
avoir à jouer en fait des ce que ce que
je suis ou ce que j'ai été quoi c'est à
dire que j'aime beaucoup les films qui
ont été fait par exemple sur la banlieue
mais je m'appelle joué un banlieusard
quoi
parce que c'est ce que j'ai été pendant
25 ans et je suis en fait le cinéma je
trouve que c'est intéressant à partir du
moment où nous-même en tant qu'acteur on
va découvrir un mode de vie ou une
mentalité
les trois choses que tu ne peux pas
refuser dans la vie c'est quoi les deux
autres le cul et la canne vous êtes sûr
vous allez faire du cinéma tout le temps
mais non je suis sûr de rien
pour l'instant je m'amuse bien au cinéma
donc je continue mais c'est vrai que si
un jour je m'amuse plus ça dépend aussi
des rôles quoi parce que nous propose
toujours des avant avant les scénarios
c'était alors c'est l'histoire d'un
immigré et puis aujourd'hui maintenant
c'est alors c'est l'histoire d'un beurre
et puis je me dis bah demain j'espère
que ça sera l'histoire d'un homme tout
court
j'espère qu'un jour je serai considéré
comme un comédien à part entière
[Musique]